so when the shootings happened over the weekend,
we had the shooting in Dayton, Ohio in the
shooting in El Paso Tech.
I knew that this was going to be the primary
story for the entire week. Of course we would
be talking about the shootings themselves.
We'd be talking about the reactions of politicians
to the shootings. We'd be talking about gun
safety regulations and all sorts of related
topics and I knew that none of them were going
to be monetized by youtube. And this is not
because youtube is targeting me or youtube
is targeting the left or the right or whatever.
It's simply because youtube has made it very,
very clear that to be what is called brand
safe. This is literally the term that they
use. You cannot talk about many real adult
serious, bad things that happen in the world.
You can talk about it, but those videos will
be demonetized. So I was texting with other
hosts over the weekend and we were all saying,
we're working for tips this week and this
is really serious stuff and I want to be very
clear with you.
These shootings and our reactions and the
reactions from our elected officials, this
stuff has to be covered. And everybody that
I spoke to knew this is what we have to cover
this week, even though it's going to significantly
negatively affect the revenue that our program
and our staff and our studio rent and all
of that stuff relies on. I could skip it all
and I could just spend the week covering Trump's
tweets and sports and, uh, you know, Mera
Donna's surgery in Argentina. You probably
didn't hear about that one, but I've been
following it, uh, and, and make a lot more
money on that. But I'm doing a disservice
to you if I do that. I couldn't live with
myself if I did that. But this is how monetization
policies shape the narrative because some
people will shy away from certain topics or
not cover them as fully as they should.
So an intermediate way would be for me to
do a story about the shootings and then to
just forget about it for the rest of the week
and not tell you let as I did earlier today
as a and is the monetized, uh, that Fox News
is parroting talking points literally from
the shooter's manifesto or talking about Donald
Trump's reactions to the shooting or talking
about Republican elected officials blaming
video games. I could choose not to cover it
fully, but that would be the wrong thing.
And so what happened is that on Monday we
had three videos related to the shootings
and all three videos were demonetized yesterday
there was more work to do, there was more
follow up to do. And literally half of the
videos we published yesterday, three of the
six as I'm showing on screen right now were
demonetized. Some of them got a ton of views
on which we made no money.
It's a video here and a video there. But when
you look at the views, because these videos
did well, which is important because that
means that people actually care about this
stuff. This week, just from Monday and Tuesday,
we had 350,000 views on these few clips. Demonetized
completely. So there are a few things at play
here. First, it's the advertisers that drive
this. It, it's not, it's easy to blame youtube
and of course youtube is complicit in the
system. It's not youtube fault per se. Advertisers
impose restrictions on youtube, particularly
since the panic of apocalypse 2017 and youtube
wants to placate them because youtube is a
for profit company. Uh, so they say anything
remotely controversial related to crime or
violence or terrorism, we will not run ads
on. We will cater to you advertisers is what
youtube effectively says, not the creators
of course. And in a way, not to the audience
either because in some way, shape or form.
Not everybody can do what we do, which is
to say, screw the monetization. I'm going
to cover what's important. There are creators
that either choose to or are sort of forced
into for financial reasons, staying away from
topics that they know are going to be demonetized.
And in a way it's so childish. It's quite
similar to censorship in television with regard
to swear words and sexual situations in other
countries like my home country of Argentina,
this is like no big deal. You know, swearing
on TV is not really a big deal in many countries.
It's much more common that when you're watching
serious news reports about bad things that
happen, even what is shown is far less sanitized
and more graphic. We can talk about the impact
on children or whatever else. That's a perfectly
legitimate conversation. But in the United
States, even adults in many cases are not
just treated like adults when it comes to
media restrictions.
So that's number one. Secondly, this goes
to the bigger problem as I've been saying,
of the connection between monetization of
content and the desires of advertisers. That
is systemically a connection that is problematic.
And so that's why, you know, I really, really,
really appreciate the people that understand
this sort of urgency and destructive nature
of that status quo and have stepped up in
the last couple of months and funded as directly
as this problem has gotten bigger and bigger
on youtube. We had a record record all time,
record new membership month in June. Awesome
July fell slightly short of that, but July
became our second best month ever for new
supporters. August is off to a good enough
start that maybe it'll come in sort of around
July right around second best and the amazing
thing is people seem to be getting it and
it could not be happening at a more important
time.
Membership culture supporting what you believe
in. This is the path forward. There are easy
ways to do it with our show, but you don't
have to do it with our show. Do it with whatever
show is important to you. Okay, membership,
this takes a minute. David. pacman.com/membership
coupon codes are available. This is 2020 saves
you 40% I'll even give you a crazier coupon
code. This one I usually don't mention except
in a very specific situations. The coupon
code half 19 h a l f 19 will save you 50%
off of the membership of your choice. If you
want something simpler, you want, not as big
of a commitment, maybe not that membership
is a big commitment. Patrion patrion.com/david
Pakman show a throw us a dollar a month. It
really does make a difference. And of course,
please make sure that you are subscribed to
our youtube channel.
A lot of people getting unsubscribed by a
quote glitch. Please subscribe to the Youtube
Channel at youtube.com/the David Pakman show,
like comment and share this video if you're
watching on youtube and support us on the
newest platform twitch. I have done, I guess
it's four live streams on twitch now. Uh,
the engagement is great. We uh, have a really
great direct connection to the audience there
and I hope you'll join me in the future on
twitch at twitch.tv/david Pacman,